hello people youtube how's your morning
going
let me tell you about mine so i was on
my way
to go on a workout and then something
stopped me in my
tracks i got an email from youtube now
i'm sure
you guys are no strangers
to hearing youtubers complain about
youtube
now also we mainly do reactions on this
channel
so with that territory we are no
strangers
to a thing called copyright claims
we get plenty of them you know what
most of the time most of the time it's
like well there's nothing we can do
nothing we could really do about it but
then i saw we got a copyright claim for
something
and it wasn't a reaction so i had to
investigate
and find out what it was
and this is the most
it's kind of funny how ridiculous
this is we did a reaction yesterday to
that
tom cruise rant and it wasn't the
reaction that got claimed
it was the first 20 seconds
of the video that got claimed and if you
guys have
seen the video you'll know what i'm
talking about it's the part where
we are chanting tom cruise's
name i'll just say it like that what how
is this
claimed so i pulled up the claim details
and here's a photo for you guys
the first 20 seconds and the copyright
owners are
all of these companies right here
apparently all these music companies
associated with sony
are claiming that we used their
song
i don't think we did i don't think we
did
when you submitted dispute there's a
couple of questions that they ask you
one of them is is this the substitution
for the original song
absolutely not that's saying it's the
mission impossible original mix
no it is not the lyrics the lyrics
are our own we're chanting one man's
name and that is the great tom cruise
and even if it's
akin to a mission impossible melody
there's no music being used and if we're
talking about the melody
we're certainly not on key we're not
even
doing like the tune we're just we're
saying tom cruise's name
the entire time we never even make it a
music
sound to it yet our video
is demonetized and our earnings off of
it
are all going towards these
companies now whether you liked our
video or not
i don't think i don't think
they deserve the earnings
that youtube is now going to be sending
their way i just find this
um to be the most silly
situation i've ever run into of course
you chat with creator support online
and uh they're like yeah we'll take it
up to the team
you submit a a request for this to be
under review
probably on a review for 30 days and
then
they'll say well we'll pay out to the
proper person
uh once a dispute is resolved and in my
experience
and a lot of other people who do youtube
i've only known
one individual and i won't say his name
just i don't think it's bad as his name
but it is
just in case i only know one individual
who has actually told me yeah actually
after uh youtube did its review
yeah a couple weeks later i got my money
that's just one
we have never had that happen for us
never i like i'm not even just talking
about reaction videos there have been
times on like reviews or sketches just
like
this is ridiculous and it's so
silly to me like wow
these companies are like hey you're
stealing money from us real rejects
you're stealing
no we're not
anyway that's my morning